- You guys in?
♫ We're unstoppable
- Hello Vlog, live from Los Angeles.
8:10am
PST.
About to go to a client
meeting here in L.A.
♫ There's a moment
♫ In your bones when
♫ When the fire takes over
♫ Blood is runnin', heart is pumpin'
- Gonna run over to Vid Summit
which should be really fun,
bunch of vloggers,
kind of the whole creator ecosystem.
Something I'm proud to be a part of,
and back at the office.
And then a slew of VaynerSports meetings
and then red eye to Cinci.
♫ We can be heroes everywhere we go
♫ We can have all that we ever want
♫ Swingin' like Ali
- On the phone with
Brandon from Wine Library.
Like, whoa,
I'm doing more than I thought I could do.
Why should that only be you?
And when he says to you,
how do I do that, all?
We're like, do it!
Let 'em go fast!
With Jeff Nicholson, chief media officer.
Just gotta delegate it
and not be the bottleneck
and we gotta pick people
that can get things done
and it's as simple as that.
With Tyler
No email left behind, Tyler!
CFO, thank you, D-Rock.
The thing that has always held back
when I'm not involved is
we go on defense, no
expenditures on offense
and then nothing happens.
You just decrease until you windle away.
Same themes: what matters, what doesn't.
At the end of the day, I think,
that has been one of
the bigger separations
for me in my career from the pack
and something that I would really,
you know how I say 99 percent
of things don't matter?
It's true.
Just 99 percent of you
don't see it that way.
And you focus on things that don't matter
and I think that
that's something you should audit.
And that's something I audit
with myself all the time.
Every year I get better at
dropping things that don't matter.
Things change too
that used to matter don't matter.
Things matter when you
have a two year old child
that don't at 13.
You can't parent a 13 year old
the way you parented them at two.
So,
just a whole slew of one hour of
this matters, this doesn't.
Let's focus on what
matters, let's execute.
Vid Summit.
2017.
Shonduras!
Shonduras you cut your hair?
- I did, it's shorter!
- [Gary] What are you,
like a professional now?
- Gary Vee's on the camera!
- Vid Summit Verse One.
- Amazing.
S'up?
Dude, it's incredible!
- [Gary] Good to see you, brother.
- What up? How you doin'?
- A pleasure.
- You recognize this guy
waiting outside our office?
- [Gary] I sure do.
- He works here now!
- [Gary] Good to see you, man.
- I work now.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- I work!
- [Gary] We got shitloads of salad.
Just an important moment in every vlog.
Just an enormous amount of salad.
- [Man] Cool.
(laughs)
- [Announcer] Gary V, guys!
(audience applauding)
- This is what I'm most worried about.
That you know it, that you're right,
you're here right now
and you're either not working hard enough
or not believing enough in
how right you actually are.
And so when I really thought about
the talk that I would give here
amongst everybody else,
I just was like, fuck,
I'm gonna suffocate the
shit out of everybody.
(audience members laughing)
In a very positive way.
(audience laughs)
So that they understand,
please, please, please,
don't look back at this
talk in three years
and be like, fuck, I
wish I listened to him
and I wish I did a little more work,
created a little more content,
took it a little bit more serious.
Because for the last decade of this
distribution disruption that
the internet has done to our society,
there have been people that have
stumbled into the moment
that you're in right now.
You're here.
And just don't realize
how far ahead they are
because you're stuck
being used to each other.
98 percent of America has no idea
what the fuck is going on in here.
I thought that was really good, D-Rock.
- Yeah I feel like you did a good job.
- I felt really, really good about myself.
- Great.
- There were some good moments, right?
- Yeah.
- I'm really starting to
figure this thing out.
- I crowd surfed at a Gary Vee event!
I want to be the first
person to crowd surf
at a Gary Vee event.
Yeah!
Crowd surfing!
(Gary laughs)
- T!
- What's up?
- How we doin', man?
- Fine, man,
I didn't know who you were before today,
but I do now and I'm very happy
- What about now!?
- I'm happy, man!
- Take care.
Thank you so much.
It's going pretty well,
but there's a fuckload
more photos to take!
Dude, it's good to see you again.
- Dude it's really good to see you.
- Real pleasure.
- Yeah.
- [Man] Alright let me introduce you
to a lot of my buddies here.
- [Gary] Yes.
- So I'm a creator, and I'm a lawyer.
And I wish we could help creators
become more sophisticated.
So you got the agencies
right now in the space
and they're taking
sometimes 50, 60, 70 percent
of a brand deal.
- That's absurd.
- A brand is paying all this money for
what they think it's worth
and then the agency comes
to creator and says,
we'll give you,
- I get it.
- But the creator
doesn't know that.
- I understand.
- I want to educate the creators
and speed up the industry so it can
become more like what now
is the real estate industry
where it's like, look,
there's a transparent fee
that's related to the matchmaker,
the independent--
- You're gonna have a tough time because
first of all, you don't
have to have a tough time,
just make content.
Like you're gonna make one video
that's gonna be like the secret
thing in influencer marketing
and it just goes.
But it'll take time because there's
five major holding companies
that control the
disproportionate amount of money
that's going in the advertising world.
And they have no interest
in what you're up to.
They want to make sure
they're hitting their numbers.
And they will fuckin' fight to keep it.
Why do you think TV still gets money?
- Yeah.
So it's trying to turn the
tide as quick as possible.
- There's just a patience, the marathon
and the consistent piece of content.
You know what scared me?
I'm saying shit I've been
saying for nine years
every fuckin' day!
- Yeah.
- It's like, you can't give up the fight.
Look at like, every issue in life.
Sexism, racism, escapism,
everything.
It doesn't speed up.
- Yeah.
- It just evolves.
So you're not gonna be
able to boil the ocean.
- Sure.
- So I would say, play your little part.
You know how I think about stuff?
I'm not the biggest, I don't
have the biggest audience.
I think that I'm consistent
and put out good stuff,
and then it influences people that have
even have bigger
And that's what you want to do.
It doesn't matter how
many subscribers you have.
You may make one piece
of content from a legal,
practical, authentic standpoint
that may get picked up by 2020.
And that helps a different
generation see it
in that 2020, 'cause
the kids in the background watch it
while their mom's watching CESA
and they make a video.
Patience.
- Okay.
We'll keep doing it.
Thanks.
- Good luck, man.
- What's your vision in
terms of diversifying?
- Diversifying?
- Right now--
- Like what I was talking
about in the audience?
- Yeah.
- Facebook.
Facebook Video is fuckin' real.
- Yeah.
- Like you guys could do so much damage.
You could target people
that are fans of Nerf,
the brand.
And put a video with you
doing Nerf shit in it.
Like YouTube has nowhere
close to the capabilities
of targeting the right audience.
You could target 15 to 19 year old dudes
that are into Nerf.
Like the shit you can do on Facebook
is so bonkers.
- Yeah.
- And YouTube native
people never realize it
and Facebook is going to
build a huge video business.
- So you think Facebook
one day will be able to
compete with YouTube?
- A hundred thousand percent.
I think Facebook competes
with YouTube right now!
Not in the way that we
all think of it here,
but it's kind of already happened.
- So Facebook--
- Like I do
much more branding and winning on Facebook
than I do on YouTube.
- And how does Facebook relate to YouTube?
If you're doing something on Facebook,
the cross traffic and all that
- That's where hacking
with that left and right.
But, I would highly recommend just
to create a Watch channel, for yourselves.
Just Google Facebook Watch
the new thing they have.
Try something.
So a lot of people who are doing
second YouTube channels
should actually be creating a
first Facebook Watch channel.
And just drive them there and
see what happens!
Because remember, there
is not the same viral loop
on YouTube that there is on Facebook.
Meaning, YouTube algorithm
hacking can happen
and the machine gives you awareness.
But if you do something rad on Facebook
people are just sharing
the fuck out of it!
- Yeah.
- Got it?
Facebook. Take it seriously.
- Awesome.
- And make one minute version
recap videos on Instagram
and drive them to YouTube.
- So the other thing you were saying is
Facebook has a different style.
- 100 percent, you gotta get used
and you figured out the YouTube thing.
Figure out the cadence and
the vibe of the other ones.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Cool.
- It's awesome.
- Sweet, thank you.
- Real pleasure,
good luck to you guys.
Good luck.
Dude, so glad we met man.
Thanks for collabin'.
Thanks for stopping through.
- Thank you for having me.
- Yeah of course, brother man.
How are you?
- Doing well, doing well.
- Good, man.
What's up man?
- How you doing?
Anthony.
- Real pleasure, my man.
Real pleasure.
How are you?
To me, I think if you
overthink prioritization,
you're gonna slow down.
What got you here was you
not thinking about that.
- That's true.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- So even at the place that I'm at,
a lot of times I just
don't overthink that.
You know, I know I'm doing my things
I got the VaynerMedia thing,
I got my brand, I got my family,
I'm trying to buy the Jets.
- Yeah.
- I know what I'm doing,
but on a micro,
I'm not as crippled of,
should I spend an extra
15 hours on the project
and the mixtape versus
should a blow up a second YouTube channel
versus should I get on Facebook Watch?
Know what I mean?
- Spending all your time focusing on--
- I think people overthink shit,
and I'm just in the yes, yes, yes
and you start surrounding
yourself with people
and just,
to me, one of the things
that Shonduras has done
that I'm passionate about is,
I'm watching him navigate
what I did which is
surround himself with
people that can do shit.
The answer is always, always people.
- Yeah.
- The answer to all your problems
slash opportunities
is more fuckin' homies you trust.
- Yeah, gettin' the right people.
- When people talk about machine learning
eliminating jobs,
these two brothers, they're going to have
57 people working for
them if they do it right.
Not one or two.
Like you become a media company.
I got 17
full-time employees working on brand Gary
and we're not even doing half the shit
that's on my mind.
We don't even have a Biz Dev guy!
Making real fuckin' money.
So, that's the best piece of advice
I can give you.
- Definitely.
- Don't beat yourself up and always
keep looking for people.
That's what you three need to be doing.
Just keep looking for people,
normally fans that are just good,
and just figure out what they're good at.
- [Man] You grab that, I grab the lunch.
- We got lunch, we got meetings,
we got Troy here taking a selfie.
- [Man] Troy!
(camera snap)
- Take care, Troy.
- Great to meet you.
- [Man] One more time, Gary.
- Let's do it.
- Milton Lawrence.
- Yes, tell 'em.
Tell 'em.
- So I produced my new show called
Will You Marry Me?
It's coming out here on Thanksgiving
but I wanted to ask you
man, really quickly.
We have the entire
season already produced.
- Yes.
- What I wanted to find out
is, I wasn't sure whether
to do it on Facebook
and/or YouTube.
- I would do Facebook.
- Really!
- Really.
Because there's a white space.
They're pushing stuff.
Start a Watch channel.
- Okay.
- And put it on Facebook.
And then run some ads
against people that like
that kind of content.
- So weddings--
- You got it.
Got it?
- Thank you.
- Take care.
(modern hip hop music)
- [Man] See you, man!
Oh, yes!
- Veggies.
I'm a huge fan of veggies.
Here's an interesting question.
Vlog, what do you like more,
Carrots
or broccoli?
Leave a comment below.
One of you is gonna get
a thousand dollars worth
of carrots or broccoli.
♫ I been thinkin' love is overrated lately
♫ Only say that 'cause I ain't got a lady
♫ You don't know me you ain't heard about
♫ That awesome thing lately
- That's all one, right?
When can I get a pair?
Should I start getting people excited?
I should, right?
Like it's time to start getting
Guys, it's comin'!
- Uh oh.
- It's fuckin' comin'!
11/14, get on it!
We're gonna sell them out in one second.
But I'm telling you right now,
just to give you momentum.
Honestly, here's my plan.
There's not a shoe to be had on Earth
on Thanksgiving.
10 days, all gone.
All out of the system.
Vayner Nation, Vlog.
We're having our Gary Vee
sneaker meeting right now.
You just heard it, I promised.
All fuckin',
what do we got here?
Two, three thousand pairs.
We need 'em all out
in 10 days.
I don't want a fuckin'
sneaker in the world.
Christmas presents, Hanukkah, fuckin',
- If you can't get them,
email Patrick.
(laughs)
- Vlog, you guys in?
I am, but, they fucked up my car.
Can I call you back in like four minutes?
Heading to some VaynerSports meetings.
Just had a great sneaker meeting.
GaryVees dropping November 14th.
Get your pair.
Long fuckin' day.
- If you were us right now,
you would stick around and be the
last person to talk to you.
So that's exactly what we're doing.
- I love it.
- And are asking for the
biggest piece of advice.
If there was one thing
that you'd recommend
to us as business majors,
no technical skills but
don't want to be a wantrepreneur,
we want to be an entrepreneur.
What would you say?
- I think, look, the thing that you've got
in your advantage is your youth.
You have so much time.
The biggest problem right now,
and it's not even remotely close,
there's nothing secondary, is
people just want shit too fast.
I didn't do shit from 20 to 30.
Fuckin' worked 15 hours a day
in a liquor store every day.
You know
- We know the whole story!
Trust me.
- My advice is very simple.
I think right now,
in the instant gratification world,
it's hard to not get seduced by
the good stuff that comes along.
I think real entrepreneurship is
being super interested in eating shit
for the next seven, eight, nine years
for real!
- No vacation, no summer.
- Yeah!
It's just like,
that's the advantage.
That's what you have.
- Right.
- You don't have the bank account yet.
You have the time!
You have the fact that it's
easy for you to, fuckin,
stay up 'til three in the morning
every fuckin' day,
and just fucking grind, right?
You have the luxury of
looking at the world with naive eyes
and being like,
why can't we?
Right?
- Right.
- It's one big game of fuckin'
playing to your strengths.
- Playing to your strengths, yeah.
- 100 percent.
The other thing is,
I wouldn't raise any money.
- Really!
- Yeah.
- Never heard that.
Wait, why?
- Never heard that before.
- I think raising money has caused
a lot of kids to not
be good entrepreneurs.
They pander to
raising more money,
and so you become a
financial arbitrage machine
instead of actually building a business.
VaynerMedia is a $125
million dollar business
that I never raised a penny for.
I figured out somebody to sell a
$40,000 dollar campaign in the beginning.
And then, the money we used.
- You heading out?
I need a hug.
- You got it, bud.
Good luck to you, man.
- Thank you so much.
- Yes, let's get in here.
(modern hip hop music)
I'm tired.
- [Man] Long day, huh?
- Yeah.